now last week uh moving on I think I
think it was last week I mentioned an
email that we got from Rolling Stone
where they were asking me for comment on
a hit piece that they were getting ready
to publish uh about me and some other
conservatives and I declined to
participate in my own hit piece as much
as I uh was you know thankful for the
office very generous offer but I
declined to participate I did say that I
would give them a comment if they could
if the Rolling Stone could first Define
the word woman so that was the deal that
I offered to find the word woman I'll
give you a comment uh they elected not
to do that the hit piece has finally
been released and I have to say of all
the hit pieces that have been published
uh this one has to be my favorite like
this is great uh so I'm going to read a
little bit of this a few minutes into
the documentary what is a woman Matt
Walsh is seen striding into the woods
with a fishing rod his plaid shirt vest
and close cropped beard giving off
Lumberjack dad energy
well let's come out here to think Ian
tones as he casts his line into the
water nature seems to always tell the
truth even when we don't want to hear it
he then asks himself a series of
rhetorical seemingly joking questions
about gender and identity is there a son
Trapped In My Daughter's body if so how
do I get him out are any of my kids who
they claim to be so begins that film
which premiered in June 2022 and
features Walsh peppering a series of
Health Care Providers politicians and
help lgbtq activists with questions
intended to expose what he refers to as
the insane ideological Cult of gender
ideology Waltz travels the world asking
people to find the word woman uh so on
and so forth it ends with Walsh posing
the question to his wife who defines the
term as an adult human female then hands
him a pickle jar to open
and the article goes into detail about
you know the origin story it says that I
quote lack the star power of my boss Ben
Shapiro but then it says this
which is true uh
that changed however with what is a
woman in early January 2022 a few months
prior to the film's debut Walsh had a
little more than 767 000 followers on
Twitter by January 2023 he had reached
1.24 million over the past month alone
Walsh has gained more than a hundred
thousand followers he now has over 2
million the film did tremendous damage
in terms of helping to quote amplify
anti-trans ideology making it mainstream
providing it to a bigger audience says
RG Cravens research analyst at the
Southern Poverty Law Center
it took advantage of the underlying
transphobia that exists in the country
it also helped legitimize Walsh as a
political Authority leading to an
invitation for him to testify in front
of the Tennessee house committee
regarding a bill Banning gender
affirming care for minors uh then it
goes into the success of the film I mean
I'm just reading through this
and I was waiting to get to the part you
know usually in a hit piece you get to
the part where it's like okay there's
the hit uh and the entire thing is just
about how the film was massively
successful and influential uh painting
me as one of the leaders of the
conservative movement and that's how
they decided to attack me and I have to
say it's really awful stuff it's so
embarrassing please
media don't don't make any more articles
like this it really hurts my feelings
it's clear that the left is giving up
their morals and any Common Sense
there's no better time to build a daily
habit of prayer and meditation building
a habit of prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude focusing on
what you're thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S it's
helped me maintain a daily prayer
routine it can help you do the same
download the app for free at hollow.com
Matt Walsh you can set prayer reminders
track your progress along the way not
sure where to start we'll check out
father Mike schmitz's Bible in a year
podcast available on the hollow app for
brief daily readings and Reflections to
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg or Jim
Caviezel and so many more with Halo you
can customize a personal prayer plan
that works for you listen wherever you
are with downloadable offline sessions
using hello to connect with others who
share your beliefs and values can
provide a sense of belonging and support
and Foster a sense of community as well
ultimately you know we'll learn how we
can become better individuals in spite
of today's broken World As We strive to
become more like Christ in our daily
lives through prayer fasting and giving
download hello.com Matt Walsh and get an
exclusive three months free that's three
months absolutely free at hello.com Matt
Walsh
I'm a shy person I don't like this kind
of attention
and especially when you're when you
write an entire article
about my successes I just please stop
doing that it really I'm begging you
don't no more no more articles like this
I I I'm throwing up the White Flag I
Surrender
but then of course you notice the one
thing they don't do in the article is uh
even try to deal with any of the
arguments or the points so of course
they call it transphobic and they and
everything else it's bigoted it's a
um but at no point do they say well
Walsh makes this claim which is wrong
because of this
or the movie you know presents this
argument and here's why it's wrong
and you think if you're gonna write like
a 5 000 word hit piece that maybe you'd
make some time for that
in fact that should be that should be
the that should be the headline
you should start with that
just dismantle the movie piece by piece
especially if you are acknowledging that
it's uh influential successful very
according to them quote damaging
damaging to their agenda which it is
then why not like why hasn't Rolling
Stone done that
you know why haven't why haven't they
why isn't why haven't any of these
corporate media Outlets done
just put put out the definitive takedown
of what is a woman and bit by bit rip it
to shreds
no one has done that
no one has done it
literally and not just corporate media
nobody on the left has done this
they've had a year and they haven't been
able to do it because they know they
can't
um which is why up until recently they
decided to just ignore it and uh now
they can't even do that anymore so this
is what they're left with thanks for
checking out this video if you'd like to
listen to my full podcast on the go you
can check out the Matt Walsh show on
Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts